egal welche fragen sie stellen aus den
endlosen russischen amateurvideos aus
dem größten truppenaufmarsch seit sechs
jahrzehnten eine antwort scheint immer
richtig zu sein man hat zu wenig geredet
was uns aber umgekehrt oder star gemacht
dass wir überall nur drohungen gegenüber
russland höheren offenkundig kaum einer
mit russland rede dass es dringend
notwendig dass diese gespräche auch auf
breitere füße gestellt werden wir können
nicht erst dann wieder miteinander reden
wenn alle konflikte ausgeräumt sind
gesucht deutschland zu wenig dialog mit
russland in den vergangenen drei jahren
hat das bundespresseamt für kanzlerin
merkel 33 treffen und telefonate mit
präsident putin vermerkt mit
us-präsident beiden waren es sieben mit
rang neun mit keinem vergleichbaren
landwirt so viel dialog geführt wie mit
russland dazu kommt dass die russische
regierung vor allem mit den usa reden
will und mehr dialog mit europäischen
dialogpartnern nicht automatisch als
mehrwert sieht wir haben europäische
internationale organisationen gesprächs
formate wie die organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
aber eben auch der europarat wo ich in
den vergangenen jahren den eindruck
hatte dass russland kein gesteigertes
interesse hat diese gesprächsformat auch
ernst zu nehmen zum tango gehören immer
zwei zu wenig dialog ist der häufigste
glaubenssatz über die deutsche
russland-politik der zweithäufigste
die nato hat russland betrogen dass
außenminister genscher 1990 in
washington vorschlägt die nato nicht
nach osten auszudehnen gilt vor allem
der linkspartei aber auch teilen der spd
als beweis für einen wortbruch des
westens russland sei fest versprochen
worden die nato nicht zu erweitern ein
beitritt hätte den osteuropäischen
staaten den baltischen ländern nie
gestattet werden dürfen also mit
sicherheit besser gewesen wenn man
diesen ländern eine neutralität status
zugebilligt hätte wissen sie natürlich
aus der geschichte heraus gibt es länder
wir wollen gerne in die nato und glauben
sie sind dann sicher aber europa wird
nicht sicher dadurch dass moskau auch
den osteuropäern mehrfach schriftlich
eingeräumt hat ihr bündnis frei wählen
zu dürfen dass moskau die nato beitritte
akzeptierte in der charta von paris zum
beispiel oder in der nato russland grund
akte werde heute vom kreml und seinen
verteidigern einfach weggelassen wehrt
sich zum beispiel die town
dieses angebliche versprechen hat es nie
gegeben wenn wir uns nicht der nato und
der eu angeschlossen hätten wären wir
heute ein umstrittenes territorium
hätten wir heute möglicherweise
russische truppen auf unserem gebiet
hände weg von russland und china am ganz
linken rand des deutschen
meinungsspektrums aber auch an ganz
rechten wird eine behauptung moskaus zur
doktrin erhoben
die ukraine werde vom westen gesteuert
die medienrevolution sei ein
faschistischer putsch gewesen
organisiert von den usa mit einem ziel
die ukraine in die nato zu zwingen die
absicht hinter dem russischen
truppenaufmarsch die absicht hinter dem
handeln moskaus halten linken-politiker
für klar
das hat ein ganz konkretes primäres ziel
die aufnahme der ukraine in die nato zu
verhindern weil das elementare russische
in sicherheitsinteressen berühren würde
dabei war ein nato-beitritt nie populär
in der ukraine bis der konflikt mit
russland begann die eu-mitgliedschaft
die war immer mehrheitsfähig in der
ukraine die nato-mitgliedschaft bis zum
bis zum krieg nicht aber mit
kriegsbeginn eben hat sich auch die
orientierung der menschen verändert auch
das persönliche empfinden die der bedarf
nach nach sicherheit die man eben nur
bei der nato gesehen hat dass die nato
die ukraine weder jetzt noch in
absehbarer zukunft aufnehmen will lassen
die verteidiger russlands meist weg egal
ob sie russen oder deutsche sind